what are easy businesses that you've you
started where you're like because I for
me milk Road was a way easier business
than any business I had ever started
um what what's been an easy business for
you and where does where does the where
does agencies rank on the easy to hard
scale I'd say it's medium I mean the
hardest let's just say the hardest
possible businesses are brick and mortar
or where you have to move physical goods
and you have a lot of employees
[Music]
all right Andrew Wilkinson you're back
what's going on
not too much good to be here
uh Sean did you know that that sahil one
that we did we had sahil Bloom on the
other day
two things were interesting to me one
people thought when we were making fun
of them that we disliked him they
thought I disliked him which is not true
and two
it was shockingly popular did you see
that well that part's not that
surprising the first part surprising I
mean we were all making fun of each
other I thought I thought it was a
fairly even give and take but maybe not
maybe it was a bit of a roast battle but
you don't you only do that with people
you like yeah exactly if you actually
don't like somebody you don't just come
out and start busting their balls that's
not to be like to be fair the guy is
like stupidly handsome I met him uh when
I was in New York very very handsome guy
so we got a on him yeah
the worst part is you want to hate those
guys but if they're nice it's almost
worse he was very nice
yeah the one thing that was really good
is he's pretty prone to like taking a
pretty like a cookie cutter response to
things because he's like he's got like a
good image he wants people to generally
like him like he's you know he's on TV
sometimes he's got his like book deal so
he's like doing things where you know
public perception kind of matters
whereas if you're just an entrepreneur
who owns some business like you don't
need everybody to like you but for his
things you know it's good when people
like him it's good for business but he
came on and he was like super honest
super open about everything and was not
giving us politician answers even though
I do think he's a future president he
wasn't doing that though so I thought
you know mad props to him for uh for
just being normal like like if we were
normally hanging out that's how he was
on the Pod it was perfect what do you
want to start you want to start with
some postmortem stuff you want to where
do you want to go with this Andrew
Andrew always sends us the best Topics
in advance where we could just we could
just pick and choose like what's this
word mean and we could riff off that but
Andrew I bet you have a sense of what
you think the most interesting topic is
so let's not bury the lead what do you
think is the most interesting topic that
you have when I started my business
um I was like Mr business Builder like
I'd say yes to absolutely everything I'd
be in the shower and have the idea of
like oh you know why doesn't this exist
and then that day I would start it and I
would just constantly be starting new
businesses like every single month and I
think it was really good because it was
like throwing spaghetti against the wall
right so it was like seeing what a good
business model is via pain so it was
just constant pain and then also running
an agency you get to see all these
startups make mistakes and learn from
them and I had this really painful
experience of starting an agency getting
really really lucky that my first
business was actually profitable because
I think one of the things that happens
is people start their first business and
fail and then they just say I I don't
like this entrepreneurship thing I'm out
and so I was able to keep going and
started another five to ten other
businesses
um and almost all of them felt like it
was incredibly incredibly painful and
after that I kind of swore off starting
businesses and I've only just come back
to it over the last three years so I can
talk a little bit about my experience
and some of those businesses Sam was
texting me before and he's like well you
start all these businesses you've like
tweeted out all these businesses what
actually happens to them so I was going
to go through a couple of those and by
the way for the for the listener this is
Andrew Wilkinson you you're on he's on
the Pod all the time owns this thing
called tiny although are you guys do you
want to go by tiny Capital now or just
tiny just tiny I hate tiny Capital yeah
I know you I I know you hated it but
everyone was like using it but oh it's
tiny which is I think one person called
you online the Warren Buffett or
Berkshire Hathaway of internet companies
so you basically buy uh and hold a bunch
of internet companies that collectively
are now doing 100 North or hundreds of
millions of dollars in Revenue whatever
the number is that you say publicly how
much did you pay your friend to say that
about you I actually it it's really
funny because there's been all these uh
uh like on the cover of Newsweek or
whatever it'll be like the next Warren
Buffett and Sam bankman freed was one of
those people and so everyone's sharing
all these covers from all these things
so being called the next Warren Buffett
is not good uh I and I'm I'm different
from Warren Buffett but I've copied a
lot of his ideas
well the next Steve Jobs that was
Elizabeth Holmes from theranosa that was
a another another one you didn't want to
get tagged with I think chamoth was
calling himself the the the new Warren
Buffett or like the brown worn Buffett
or something like that he called himself
that he called himself uh or I don't
know if you call I don't know I don't
want to put Like the quote on it but he
definitely insinuated it and he
definitely said we're trying to build
you know the next Berkshire Hathaway
blah blah blah and so you know he he was
given that or he named himself by the
way my favorite thing about tremoth
um was that in his annual shareholder
letters he would uh he would compare
himself to Berkshire Hathaway so he
would track social capitals results
versus Berkshire and then one year he
just stopped and I think it was the one
year that he didn't actually beat them I
think I don't recall that might be
unfair characterization but that's my
recollection so where are you going with
this you wanna do the post-mortem thing
sure is that is that where you're going
I don't know yeah let's do it we can go
through a couple of those I think it's
kind of interesting can you start with
pixel Union I think that's incredibly
interesting yeah so
um was running metallab and I uh was
like an early Tumblr user and I met
David carp just via Tumblr like he was
he was the CEO of Tumblr and he kind of
knew all the early users and stuff and I
ended up making a Tumblr theme that I
wanted to use myself and he was like hey
this is really really cool I would love
it if you could create some more of
these and we're going to make a premium
marketplace where other people can pay
to buy Tumblr themes and so I'm kind of
thinking like oh this is a favor for a
friend and this is a really small
platform I'm not thinking of it as a
business but I ended up going to a bunch
of my designers and saying hey look you
know over the weekend would you be able
to whip up some themes and so I go to
one of my interns like like literally a
guy who was like my brother's friend who
had like just finished like doing a I
think a Philosophy degree and I was like
Hey like turn this into whatever you you
want and so we ended up calling it pixel
Union and it started doing like ten
thousand dollars a month of Revenue and
it was my first taste of automatic
Revenue like I would go to sleep and I'd
wake up in the morning and we would have
sold you know 500 bucks worth the worth
of these Tumblr themes and uh Shopify
noticed what we were doing for Tumblr
and they said and at the time they were
a tiny company there were about 15
people and they said hey can you guys
also do the same thing for us and so we
got into the theme World
um for Shopify and Tumblr Tumblr
obviously died post Yahoo acquisition
and the business still exists today
um it's a really interesting story
actually so we
so I I started incubated the business
didn't raise any outside Capital spun it
out of metal lab became its own
independent company
um we ended up selling it in 2014
and then I stayed on the board I kept 20
of it and then a couple years ago I
bought it back and then we ended up
taking it public and that became we
Commerce what did you sell it for like
10 or 15 million dollars I think I read
about it publicly I sold it for 7
million
seven million dollars why would you sell
that
well at the time I was doing I think
500k of net profit and I didn't to be
honest it was one of those things where
I didn't know how good the business was
and I hadn't read anything about
investing yet and so I didn't know how
to value a business and so it was a
double-edged sword because I sold this
incredible business for
um you know a good amount of money it
allowed me to kind of have a sense of
comfort and retirement and all that kind
of stuff but doing so I suddenly had
this pile of cash and I had to learn how
to invest it and so I started reading
about Warren Buffett and reading all the
investing books and going oh my God I
can't believe I just sold that
incredible business you know it was
growing at 50 a year and you know I
thought it was great to get a 14x
multiple but not when it's growing that
fast so I regretted it
and then what did you guys pay for it
when you bought it back
so we bought it back for 26 million
and then we
um did a bunch of Acquisitions and then
we took it public when you bought it how
big was it when you bought it back uh I
think it was doing about
four million dollars of annual profit so
it grown a lot
um and we paid 26 and then we bought 460
and a couple other businesses and then
we took it public at a 260 million
dollar valuation
and when you uh you said I didn't know
anything about investing and blah blah
at that time I think today people look
at you as somebody who knows a lot about
investing and they want to be like you
when it comes to investing or buying
businesses
um what year was that when you said that
state when you felt that way because I
I'm guessing it wasn't like
that long ago is that 10 years is that
12 it was eight years ago 2014. so
that's basically eight years so less
than a decade going from I feel like I
know nothing about any of this to
you know I don't know what you're like
in the top percentile uh you know in our
in our industry and have had phenomenal
success I think that's just sort of a a
nice thing it's like if you were willing
to put in a decade
um you can go from literally the bottom
to the top and that's pretty cool
yeah I think it was you know getting
obsessed right I think that
um when you there's no better feeling
than you know picking up a book about
something and just desperately reading
it like you can't stop going through it
and I spend probably two full years just
reading every single book I could get on
I could get about value investing
um so yeah I think with intensive time
you can do it and the nice thing is
there's that great Buffett quote where
he says I'm a better businessman because
I'm an investor and I'm a best better
investor because I'm a businessman and
Chris and I we were natural investors
within our own business we knew how to
allocate Capital within the business to
drive growth and profits and margins and
all that kind of stuff so when we became
investors we were much better at it I
think because we did operational lens we
could look at a business and say oh
that's really hard or hey they're not
doing these three easy things that we
did at our company and I think one of
the big problems with investors these
days is they're often what I call
spreadsheet investors they look at a
business like a spreadsheet and they go
oh it's easy we'll just increase margin
by 20 percent not realizing that in
order to do that you have to convince a
hundred people to change
um what uh let me back off that real
quick so have you did Sam did we talk
about this Warren Buffett Sees Candy
letter I know I had it on our list I
don't know if we ever did it on the Pod
did we did we talk about this you it's
been on your list you've never you've
never brought it up so Andrew you're
like a you know Warren Buffett PhD so
you you probably know this but maybe not
I had never seen this before so there
was a letter in 1972 that Warren Buffett
wrote to the CEO of C's candy after they
had bought Sea's candies and um have you
read this before if not I just put it in
the in the chat because it's kind of
amazing I want to talk about it this was
this was very surprising to me so I put
in the chat here in Riverside but
um okay so I think of Warren Buffett as
this like kind of like what I see today
there's this guy who's super smart
really like you know likable Storyteller
he's an investor he's you know he
doesn't look like an operator he's like
a geezer right he's just sitting there
and his at his table and he reads all
day and you know he makes investment
decisions he's a capital allocator
but when you read this letter you
realize like how detailed and in the
weeds he was and how business savvy was
so I actually want to read out parts of
this real quick so that you know people
who aren't reading it can dude this is
this is terribly I mean sorry this is
incredibly well written he's he's got
such a good voice he goes dear Chuck uh
I was at Brandy's a couple days ago and
I have a few strong Impressions to pass
along so he visited the store and here's
here's his Impressions he goes uh people
are going to be affected not only by how
our candy tastes but obviously what they
hear about it from others as well as the
retailing environment in which it
appears this means like the class of the
store the method of packaging the
condition it appears the surrounding
merchandise just like the New Yorker
creates a different editorial
environment for Lord and Taylor ad than
it does for Village Voice so do the
surroundings of our candy affect the way
that our potential customers mental and
gastronomical impression of our quality
you know of course you know of course
you of course know this better than I
right so that that was the first piece
which he's basically talking about like
you know the the store environment you
know like the way that Apple you know
sort of recreated the retail store he's
already thinking about this and sending
this like more like an operational and
almost like it's like a design note
right he's not talking about margin he's
not talking about like you know debt
he's talking about the the merchandising
of the store and how it feels and how
that's going to affect how people taste
uh taste and stuff
um then he goes and he talks about
um
uh let's see what's the next uh good bit
so he's like number three yeah he goes
that Brandy's our product suffers in
comparative way against Stovers he goes
they have extremely well organized
well-displayed attractive area put uh
featuring nothing but their candy
um we've taken a number of our boxes put
them on the counter with 25 other
offerings offering cheap bulk candy and
other run-of-the-mill products and they
you know so he's talking he's basically
comparing this the store design and then
if you go down he goes um
so he's talking about the merchandising
for a while and then he goes um he's
like we may well want to have a have
descriptive material maybe our own
little booklet called the most famous
Kitchen in the world or something of
that sort Coors gets a lot of mileage
out of the fact that all their beer
comes from One Brewery and I do think
there's certain there's a certain
Mystique attached to products from with
a geographical uniqueness maybe grapes
from a little part of Italy or France
um are really the best in the world but
I've always had a suspicion that 99 of
it is just in the telling about it and
one percent is in the drinking right so
he's talking about like you know like
sort of this marketing psychology about
that you know giving them like ideas for
catchphrases and slogans this is way
more active and sort of like the brain
switched on in terms of operating than I
had thought uh what is this was a
surprise for you too Andrew or is this
something you knew about that's one of
the things I found really inspiring
about Buffett is everybody like to be
honest my impression was always like
okay entrepreneurs are the people that
do the work the investors are people
that shuffle paper around on Wall Street
and what I realized with Buffett is that
he actually was someone who yes he owned
the businesses but he influenced the
businesses massively and he made them
grow and you know brought them together
and did Acquisitions there's so many
ways where he built value right which
you can't say about a lot of people like
BlackRock doesn't build value they just
index they own a bunch of pieces of
paper Warren Buffett actually grow stuff
what's fascinating though and I'd be
curious to know whether he would still
write a letter like this is Chris and I
had dinner with Charlie Munger a couple
years ago and we asked him how involved
do you get with the CEOs and he really
said
um I'll never forget this he goes I've
never been able to change someone's mind
if someone has an idea about something
they want to do I've never been able to
talk them out of it and so you know he
said there's always opportunities within
their businesses to tweak them and make
changes and all that kind of stuff but
it's just very hard to actually get CEOs
to do stuff CEOs are not puppets they
have their own brains and they want to
do their own thing and you know two men
with a hammer everything looks like a
nail do you ever get bored just being an
investor
yeah
very that's why he starts all those
businesses yeah exactly dude it's so
boring that's why I don't really do it
it's so boring I told you it's like um
it's like yeah it's like imagine if you
know someone came along and was like Hey
look you don't have to work and you can
have all this free time and just read
all day and it sounds like a luxury when
you're a stressed out entrepreneur but
actually doing it in practice you have
to find new things to fill your time
with and you don't get your hands on the
tools right so you don't get the sense
so like for example you know we bought
Aeropress and when we first bought it I
helped Drive the redesign of the website
which you know I was proud of but I very
quickly had to let go of it I knew I
couldn't keep you know holding on to the
business and so I you know we hired a
CEO and I had to pass in the Baton and
let go and yes I get a sense of like
pride of ownership but as the business
progresses I don't feel the lifts I
don't feel the gains can we talk about
that acquisition
sure so the background here is Aeropress
for like it's almost like a coffee snob
product uh I I owned it I loved it it
was basically like a more convenient
French press that you could travel with
I love it
on their own I still own I own two of
them I have one that I have one that I
travel with and I have one that just
stays in the cabin I use it every
morning uh I love it but it was only
sold I'm almost positive I would only
see them in mom and pop coffee shops and
maybe Amazon I don't even know if they
were on Amazon but I like so the retail
wasn't that great uh but like it was
clearly like a good product it's one of
those products that like consumers can
buy for 20 bucks but even the coffee
snobs are like this is the best way to
do it uh and and you guys purchased it
recently which it's not exactly an
internet business but you're trying to
make it a little bit more internet
related but uh are you happy with this
deal I know you guys paid it seemed like
a lot of money you paid a premium for it
absolutely I mean I think um when I look
across all the businesses that we own
and I think about what business could
exist in 50 years there's a very very
small number I mean most businesses die
and I think that Aeropress is something
that has
um potential lasting impact and can be
around for decades and it was just an
incredibly unique business I mean when
do you get the opportunity to buy a way
of making coffee it's like how do you
value buying Kleenex right the word for
the way of making coffee that's written
on Grinders and is a verb almost
no I think it's sick man Sean did you
see he bought this
yeah I'm not a coffee guy like I
literally don't drink coffee so even
though I had heard of the brand it
didn't I didn't know enough about it or
didn't sort of
didn't have too much of a you know
opinion on it uh because it's not my
thing but it does remind me of like I
was looking at SodaStream and I was like
I really love this type of this category
of product I think it's a fantastic
category where it's a thing that another
device that gets in that can get into
every kitchen and has like this sort of
consumable you know refillable component
to it so that's great and then if you
become the de facto device like you said
I think you just said like the verb
basically like if you could become a
verb I just read this recently with
someone who's like you know I learned 25
years ago if something becomes a verb
just invest and uh you know it's pretty
true right Google it we'll Uber there
you know like you you realize that these
verbs tend to become like de facto
winners of uh of their category and so
I've definitely definitely uh think it's
a good idea I just don't gonna drink
coffee myself so it's the only business
that I own that people like when I tell
people and you know I you know if I'm in
Tech and you say oh yeah we own dribble
and they're a designer like they know
what that is they think it's cool they
might like give me a little nod or
something like that but if you tell like
I'll talk to you know uh the carpenter
working in my house and say oh yeah I
own Aeropress and if they know what it
is they are passionate about it and
they're excited about it and that is
very rare so um it's a really good
amazing business I remember reading uh
about this in priceonomics the guy who
created it he was like this you know now
now he's quite quite old I think I think
he's in his 80s and he was like an
inventor he was like a wacky scientist
inventor like stereotype guy where he
also cre created like uh the Frisbee or
like uh what was the Frisbee there
you remember those commercials there was
like we could throw this frisbee over a
football field or something like that
and he created all this amazing stuff
and he just had owned Aeropress that he
created but it he wasn't like a business
guy wasn't he just wasn't this kind of
just sitting uh kind of just like on
autopilot I wouldn't say it was on
autopilot he had a really great
president who is running the business
side but they were both older guys and
they were really focused on the retail
Channel which you can see there's a
reason why if you walk into 95 percent
of gourmet coffee shops anywhere in the
world they sell Aeropress but when we
looked at it just a very very small
percentage of sales were online it just
wasn't a focus for them so we came in
and there's just a ton of best practices
and Sean it's funny you mentioned
SodaStream we actually hired the
president of Sodastream us who grew the
business to 200 million in the United
States that's the new CEO of Aeropress
so
yeah I read about that person because I
was researching SodaStream and I was
like oh damn this person was like you
know they they were I don't know the
driver or the trigger of a lot of a lot
of growth that happened for SodaStream
because so didn't SodaStream sell a
couple times
um like it's owned by Pepsi now
something like that I think it's owned
by um what is it
um oh my God
I think it's it's an Israeli company I
don't know if they've sold they might
have sold to jab Holdings or someone
like that yeah I think they have so yeah
no no it's a Sodastream was acquired for
3 billion in 2018 by Pepsi
but maybe now it's owned by somebody
else I don't know there was some story
like that where it kind of like flipped
hands I thought
um and I I was thinking that there
should be like more competition for this
like there's uh there's so many d2c
Brands and I feel like the d2c so to
stream competitor
um should win I know there's a few of
them out there but uh I'm surprised I
don't hear about these more I'm
surprised there's not 100 million you
know a d2c SodaStream competitor that's
doing you know north of 100 million in
sales I feel like that's a like that
should be a thing because SodaStream is
very not D to C totally should we talk
about some of the terrible businesses
yes those are more fun so and then I
want to talk about a new business I'm
starting actually because I got yet
another one because I'm a glutton for
punishment
um okay so some of the early stuff that
I did so
um I had the idea that
um
I had cats and I was like okay all cat
furniture is hideous like it just ruins
your house it looks horrible and so I
went out and I found a couple like kind
of mom and pop brands that were doing
this and I said hey I'm going to start
an online store for cat furniture called
h.j Muse spent a whole bunch of money
designing an e-commerce website and I
um you know poured probably 300 Grand
into it which at the time was a lot of
money for me you know my whole business
was maybe making 800 Grand of profit a
year and I just learned how brutal a
business e-commerce was that you know I
was basically eking out these razor thin
margins whereas in my agency or in pixel
Union I was making 30 to 50 ebitda
margins I was making like two or three
percent and the amount of work required
to move physical Goods around by
inventory I realized that while on paper
I was profitable I was constantly taking
my profits and putting them into buying
more inventory and so I ended up
shutting that business down and losing I
think I lost all the money I put into it
but it was a great lesson in just hard
businesses I didn't realize that
different businesses were
um harder than others right like you
kind of just when you when you when
you're inexperienced in business you
stumble into these things and I always
go like God I'm so lucky I didn't start
a restaurant as my primary first
business right because it's so brutal
right it teaches you so much but it
would be so easy to tap out and just
think you don't like entrepreneurship a
restaurant was my first business
um and then he went into Ecom and then
however you come you know The Road Less
Traveled maybe uh so so what uh what are
easy businesses that you've you started
where you're like because I for me milk
Road was a way easier business than any
business I had ever started
um what what's been an easy business for
you and where does where does the where
does agencies rank on the easy to hard
scale I'd say it's medium I mean the
hardest let's just say the hardest
possible businesses are brick and mortar
or where you have to move physical goods
and you have a lot of employees so one
of the hardest businesses I own is I own
a bakery in Delhi in Victoria a BC where
I live and I bought it because I my my
brother had grown up working there it
was a Neighborhood Place the owner
wanted to sell and I've owned it for
about five or six years and I mean they
have to have about 40 or 50 employees
someone has to wake up at two in the
morning and go into the basement of the
bakery and bake croissants and the
amount of coordination that has to go
right where if a couple people are sick
how messed up the business can be is
just night and day compared to any
internet business dude if the if the if
the manager of that Bakery bails are you
gonna who's gonna go out and find a new
manager I have I have a restaurant group
like a food and Hospitality Group so I
have a guy who runs that now before I
was me I mean they would text me and say
Andrew the deep fryer is broken I need
an approval to buy a new one or whatever
it is
um so I've put people in place between
there
um in the medium Camp of challenge I
would say agencies so agencies are
beautiful in that they are asset light
so really you don't even need an office
these days but you really just need an
office and internet connection and a
keyboard and
um you can hire generally the people as
you need them and so you don't really
need any investment
um they're they're scalable
um but they're hard in that you're
constantly balancing supply and demand
so metalab for example if metalab was to
do all the work that came to it at any
given time it could probably be five
times bigger but in order for us to get
five times bigger we would have to grow
the company too fast and we would ruin
the culture and so I would would say
that agencies are a little bit like a
law firm or an accounting firm or our
consulting firm where you've got this
kind of flat linear growth that happens
over time so I think they're great
businesses but there's feast or famine
right and you really have to be prepared
for a downturn and you need to be
unfortunately ready to make radical
changes in the business at the drop of a
hat if your pipeline's not looking good
and that kind of stuff so it's just very
um very difficult in that way of course
every agency owner I know wants to own a
SAS software company and every SAS
software company owner I want or that I
know wants to own like a Consulting
business or something that grows really
fast so grass Always Greener the easiest
business that I own is a company called
wework remoli This is a job board that
we bought from Jason freed and David
heinemeyer Hansen at base camp they had
started it
and it was like the remote job board
they had written a book about remote and
they had great SEO they ended up ranking
number one for remote jobs and as you
know remote work has taken off over the
last five years and so we bought that
business from them and it really it was
just kind of sitting idle and so with
some very simple best practices and a
very very small team we were able to
build it into a very large business
what about SAS where would you put you
know SAS businesses that you've run
uh well I've lost a lot of money doing
SAS I mean I think a lot of people know
the story of flow the project management
software that I built where I basically
poured 10 million dollars into it
because I was competing with Asana and
didn't understand the dynamic of when
you're competing against uh you know
you're fighting an army that has
unlimited budget it's like Fiji fighting
the United States right and I'm going
like I'm gonna win this it's ridiculous
and so I lost 10 million dollars uh
doing that and that was a great lesson
but
um incredibly painful and I wish someone
like me had tweeted and I could have
read it instead of losing all that money
how many agencies do you own right now
um or partially owned probably own 10 10
or 12. there was um there was uh what's
the guy's name who's the richest black
guy in America Robert Smith I think his
name uh Beast is it Vista Equity Vista
Equity so basically Vista Equity is a PE
firm that owns they're they're mainly
SAS and I think if I remember correctly
the article said that they own 200
million or sorry
was it a hundred billion I whatever it
was it was it was north of 100 billion
of of SAS Revenue I think it was second
only to Salesforce in terms of their
reach and he had this uh thing where he
was saying look on our companies we're
actually only seeing a 20 decrease from
where we thought we would be this year
meaning like only a 20
um he's like we're growing at 20 a year
we thought we were going to grow at 25
so we're seeing a small decrease in the
growth that we expected therefore we
actually are pretty bullish on the
economy with your agency since you
mostly sell to big companies like slack
and whoever else you sell to are you
seeing a Slowdown from American
companies buying services
yeah absolutely I think we're seeing
softness over the next six months and
things are definitely slowing down or if
they're not slowing down people want to
achieve the same things but for less
money uh and so there's these pressures
you know like I said is this supplier
demand problem and you've got the labor
market where people are demanding more
and more pay and then you've got your
clients crunching you down right so
right now
um you know I think that it's unclear so
the other problem is it's really hazy
and so you get into these situations
like when covid hit we had a brutal
three-month period where the pipeline
dried up and then everything was fine it
really depends on what the market
sentiment is whereas if you own a SAS
business what are the odds that
someone's going to take especially a
sticky one what are the odds they're
going to rip it out of their company and
retrain everyone on that and plus
they're only being reminded they pay for
it once a year right it's I always think
it's better to have 10 000 people paying
you a small amount of money than 100
people paying you a lot of money
and what uh what's famous original
so
um I would say the theme for me is that
I will often do the wrong business
before I find the right business so for
example
um I started a I I always I'm a designer
and I always fetishize the idea of
having brick and mortar businesses I was
so sick of doing all these internet
things I wanted to sing in my own City
and so I came up with this restaurant
concept of like a bar and Pizzeria
called famous original and me and some
friends did it together and we basically
learned the hard way that restaurants
are brutal you know we were like super
egotistical we're like oh we're great
entrepreneurs we're gonna be able to
nail it in restaurants and Sean is I
I've definitely heard you talk about
your experiences here uh and nodded
along we just learned it was the most
brutal business in the entire world and
we're shocked by how much money we could
lose and so we you know hired the wrong
management we got the incentives wrong
uh we overspent on the build out to the
point where we could never get our money
back you know labor shortages we had
slippage there was there's tons of
issues but what I learned from that was
what is a badly run garbage restaurant
look like and then when the deli and
bakery came up I was like oh oh this is
a good one like this has been around for
25 years stable earnings great general
manager what type of food we just let it
run uh Pizza
you could screw up a pizza place I would
have thought that had been one of the
easier places to easier of the heart
yeah because like you don't need it's
like pretty simple ingredients uh I I
wouldn't have thought you were going to
ruin that one
now we managed to do it
[Music]
first
cut HubSpot is easy to adopt and
actually looks gorgeous I think I love
our new CRM our software is the best
HubSpot grow better you have a couple on
this list you got things you did in the
past you have things new businesses
you're doing now but I'm curious
do you have I guess like we haven't
talked to you in a while have you have
you had any ideas for businesses that
you're not starting currently but you're
like someone could do that or someone
should do that or I wish someone is you
know gonna capitalize on this
opportunity or trend
is there anything that that comes to
mind uh for ideas that you're not
currently acting on so I might have
talked about this idea in the past but
I've had this idea for a long time
um I like the idea of a service that
allows you to get on one person's radar
right so I choose let's say that I let's
say I want to sell my company in the
next two years and I think the right
buyer is this you know this x let's say
HubSpot right I want to Target darmesh
so everywhere darmesh goes on the
internet I want him to see stuff about
my company and I want him to think we're
huge there's I forget where the quote
comes from but there's this idea that if
someone sees you five times they think
you're everywhere so if you're on five
podcasts they listen to they deem you a
huge celebrity and a success or whatever
it is right so I think I want that but
hyper targeted and I think it's worth a
lot of money so I would pay ten thousand
dollars a month to be on darmesh's radar
everywhere he goes and so I don't know
how it gets done it's like a advertising
sniper rifle essentially but I really
like the idea of something like that so
I have a story about this so my best
friend his name is Jack Smith he sold
his company called vungle for 800
million dollars right before the
pandemic when he was like 29 years old
the way that he started it was he uh was
in England living in England as a
college student and he had this idea and
he wanted to go to a accelerator called
what was it called Sean do you remember
Angel pad Angel pad and the guy who run
it run ran it was his name Thomas and
Jack missed the deadline to join the
incubator and so what he noticed on
LinkedIn he goes let's advertise just to
Thomas and he said uh on LinkedIn the
way it worked is you could advertise to
like it said like only show this to
people uh like 100 people a day and he's
like wow you can go to 100 people a day
what if I just moved it to like 10
people a day and they allowed in him to
and it says all right only show this to
10 people a day but make it so they have
to work in San Francisco and they have
to work at Angel pad and the ad said hi
we're trying to reach Thomas please tell
us to contact us and he did that and it
worked and they led him into the
incubator and six or seven years later
the company sold for 800 million dollars
and we at the hustle wrote an article
about this it went viral and Linkedin
changed how they did it you can't
actually advertise they won't tell you
how many people you're going to reach
per day or something like that totally
something like that would be amazing or
even just figuring out like okay what
let's let's just do this so so I get
darmesh's email and I run it through
some sort of database and I go what
email newsletters does he subscribe to
or what podcast like how do you I don't
know if it's possible but what is his
information diet and then how do I
appear and all those things that's crazy
yes I think that would work wonderfully
yeah I would love it if someone wants to
start that business please email me
because I think it's a great idea
um but yeah there's I'm mean again like
I come up with tons of ideas but that
one has stuck with me for three years so
I feel like it's something good yeah
what could go wrong just uh targeting
somebody wherever they go everywhere
they look
what can go wrong here
um okay she's buying a billboard by his
house so that's one uh what about some
other ones I know you got more Let me
let me talk about the new thing that
we're doing so and this has been
something that's been driving me crazy
forever so you guys know what investment
bankers are
yeah I know a lot of people call
themselves that yeah right but a lot of
people kind of go like oh that's like a
stock broker or you know they work at a
bit confusing investment bankers are
realtors for businesses they go and they
represent you and they sell your
business for you or they raise capital
for you and I didn't really understand
that world at all
um so like I like I said earlier I have
only understood Finance for eight years
and I would say really only over the
last two or three years have I actually
tapped the world of Finance like gotten
proper banking credit learned how to
sell businesses learned how to use the
investment bankers but I think those
that stuff is not really accessible to
Founders and frankly they don't speak
the language of investment bankers the
investment bankers are the spreadsheet
business people right they look at your
business as a spreadsheet and they want
something that's simple and easy to
understand and frankly like I was kind
of allergic to them because I didn't
speak their language they would come and
talk to me and they would use terms like
ebitda and you know gross margin and all
these things I didn't really think about
as a founder and so I have been looking
for a firm for years
um that I can use to either sell small
businesses when I say small I mean like
kind of one to five million dollars of
ebitda or help Founders do secondaries
or all these sorts of things or even
just Finance M A and I'm yet to find
someone everyone seems to specialize in
larger businesses or they're too small
and so
um last year Chris and I met this young
investment banker and he was just a
normal person like we had him out for
lunch and he was not wearing a suit and
he was saying how miserable he was and
how much he hated you know his his old
job doing it and we we kept saying like
look like you should quit your job and
come work with us and we'll start a
modern Investment Bank for Founders
really focused on bootstrap Founders
because they don't know how to access
capital and so we we're starting this
business called Tenzing we started like
a month ago and the idea is Tenzing
Norgay is the most famous Sherpa of all
time so he helped Edmund Hillary climb
Mount Everest
um and so basically the idea is
um you can go to him and say look what
are all my options right I you know can
I get credit from the bank uh can I
raise debt to do M A can I do a
secondary can I sell my business and
they can basically walk you through all
of that stuff in a way that's aligned
and not fee driven and more long-term
Focus so we're basically starting our
own little Investment Bank
is that going to work
dude because if you are if you're if
you're a startup and you're in the if
you use the word bake right now I hate
you
no it's not I mean it's not they're not
taking any money I I mean I could just
call it business we're starting a
business realtor firm but the term is
Investment Bank there's no banking we're
not holding anyone's money uh there's no
tokens I'm not going to Argentina
yeah do you like billions of dollars or
not I think like I don't know if you
guys have experienced this but like even
here in Canada so
um for like five years I wasn't aware of
this but the government will actually
pay 30 of your r d when you're a small
company and I just didn't know about
that and so I literally lit a million
dollars on fire I could have gotten a
million dollars of these tax credits and
I didn't right I could have used a
credit line to buy ads for my SAS
business but I didn't know how to do
that
um I could have sold businesses that
were working but I didn't really want
that just kind of died like I let them
die right so I think it's about like how
do you get how do you get the most out
of what you have
um and giving people tools to do that
and it's just I wish this had existed
when I was starting out
yeah I I totally agree you know most uh
investment bankers don't work with
startups
um because they're too small or the
deals are too small or whatever so how
are you going to get it to how do you
get how are you going to get the numbers
to work because I don't think they're
doing it because they discriminate I
think they're doing it because the
money's not there for them so how do you
make that work
well it's not small businesses right I
mean like we're really focused on
bootstrap businesses because that's
where we come from and these are
companies that are doing you know two
three million dollars maybe 500k of
profit some of them are actually bigger
so we've talked to Founders that are
like hey I've got like a you know 10
million ARR business I'm doing three
million dollars of profit I was thinking
I want to sell 30 of my business and we
kind of go okay well we have the network
we've gone and you know raised all these
funds and met all the people in finance
let's connect the dots between these
people and be the financial translators
once I just linked you guys to the
website it's tenzing.com but you can
kind of see what we're doing
what's been the biggest oh dude I
thought you said you hated these
Graphics you have the graphics of like
the people with like the funny arms and
funny fingers uh if I remember correctly
you tweet it out if you see another page
like this you're gonna kill yourself or
something like that no no it was the um
the like weird Russian looking ones that
Dropbox was using for a while they were
like so weird and depressing what uh
what oh dude I know you I know these
folks I've met Rob before Rob is in our
world I don't that's funny it's such a
circle jerk world that we live in do you
just like you just collect people on
Twitter is what you do
Rob actually lives in Victoria so I've
known him for a long time he runs uh
outweigh the sock business that's right
I just launched a custom they just
launched a custom sock business you guys
should get some MFM socks made we did
we're I've gotten them for this other
thing but what uh what's been the
biggest business that you've sold so far
was it the uh Fitness thing or the meal
plan thing yeah yeah we bought a
business called me lime
um and we sold it to Albertsons
I thought you started it no we bought it
so um there was a guy
um up in Nanaimo who's a developer and
um he uh started this business with two
co-founders and his two co-founders
after the first year didn't want to be
in the business anymore and so we they
owned 70 we came in we bought them out
and Mitch the founder was basically like
look guys like I'm already growing this
business I know exactly what I want to
do just leave me alone like we tried to
write the Warren Buffett letter and say
like oh you should do this on growth or
whatever any bisc you just said leave me
alone and so he said okay fine we'll
leave you completely alone and a couple
years later uh Albertsons came and they
bought it for tens of millions of
dollars and it was a great deal for
everyone and uh yeah it worked out
really well do you think that in the
future you're gonna sell anything are
you just gonna keep on buying and keep
on holding
you don't want to sell do you no I don't
like selling and I think that um it's
really hard to predict what's going to
end up being large and how large it can
be and then
um also if you think about it like if
you have a business and it's dying it's
hard to predict how quickly it will die
and how much profit will come out of it
and usually when a business is dying you
can't sell it for much right let's say
the business is on a major downslope you
might get like one times profit and so
you're basically making a bet that it's
gonna die before a year which very few
businesses die that quickly and so
usually it's better off just to hold
forever I've found
um you know you will see like Warren
Buffett sold off his newspapers I think
that was partly because the writing was
on the wall but also because it's like
unions and a lot of complexity and they
wanted to get out of that
um but no I mean I I don't ever want to
sell businesses that's something the
only reason we sold me lime was because
Mitch wanted to sell the business he
came to us and said I want this exit and
we weren't gonna hold him back because
he was the founder we um we just did
this thing on the FTX Saga and I know
that you like have historically been I
don't know if you call yourself
anti-crypto but you're definitely not
pro crypto and you're for sure not pro
nfts and all that other of
which I agree with you what what's been
your take so far in watching all this
drama
um I think it's really really bad for
crypto I think that you know Sam bankman
freed is somebody who I certainly had
thought oh maybe this is one of the good
guys and I'd seen him uh do the podcast
circuit
um and he seemed like a smart guy and I
think that when the number two you know
if you think about these like Banks it's
like that's the equivalent of like JP
Morgan going out of business just
suddenly and everyone losing their money
um so I think it probably has a lasting
negative effect on crypto and Trust
um and it's been fascinating watching
the price of crypto not react the way
you would think where you know inflation
you'd think would drive the price of
Bitcoin up it doesn't appear to have
done that
um to be honest I'm not I was saying
this to a friend of mine I think I've
probably said it on the show before but
if you came to me and you said hey I
think British pound sterling I'm super
bullish on them because XYZ macro event
was happening I would just say why are
you currency trading you're a tech
entrepreneur and I think that Bitcoin is
currency trading right like just buy
great businesses do the thing you know
and I think everyone is just speculating
on this stuff and there's a ton of
fascinating Arguments for it and I
follow it but I have just fully steered
clear and I'm sure that we'll invest in
a crypto business at some point but for
now I'm just waiting for it to play out
more
um one important reminder is if you if
you missed Amazon you had until 2010 to
invest in it there's a lot of time to
wait and sit and watch to find these
great businesses
uh two things one uh
that thing you just said reminds me of
something Kevin Trump told us once he
goes
um we go what you know you've been
trading for 20 plus years uh you know
what are the biggest lessons or
something like that and I asked him some
some stupid question like that and he
goes well well you know there's no less
of blah blah then he goes one thing
there's always a second chance on the
train it goes even when it's a winner
even when it's a good thing you'll
always get a second chance on the train
and um you know so so that sort of takes
away a lot of the fomo when you realize
that that you know there you do get
these second opportunities you know it
happened with Amazon it happened with
Facebook it happened with many many
businesses where even if you weren't
early and correct
um
these things go up and down now the hard
part is uh it's when they go down that
you have the least conviction so it
could be that that right now is the
right time you know now might be the
second time to get on that train because
prices are down but now is when people
are the most scared and the most
hesitant to act on if you were hesitant
before you probably triple hesitant now
and so I think that's the hard part for
to try to get back on the train when uh
when there is a dip uh the second thing
is we talked about red flags and fraud I
think on the last time you're on here we
talked about people who were lying or
our partners who had screwed you uh with
the FTX thing did you hear of anything
or was there anything red flaggy that
you had heard either along the way or
once it started to come out that you're
like oh that sounds pretty bad actually
that's that was a bit of a tell now
either in hindsight
no I mean I like you guys
um I I am
I just haven't fall I I guess I hadn't
followed it super closely and I hadn't
really spent a lot of time on that
particular business
um I was quite shocked that he was known
for risk management and he had been
talking you know was very assertive
about talking about the security of the
balance sheet and it seems like there's
a lot of uh loans going on between
related party businesses where he's
bailing out his own business and stuff
so very sketchy what I find fascinating
is is this a bad actor right is he a
psychopath who's building a Ponzi scheme
or is he just somebody who got in over
his head and used Too Much leverage uh
and messed up and I I don't really have
an assessment of that yet and to be
honest I'm not following it super
closely I'm kind of waiting to read the
book I find like waiting for this stuff
to all blow up and wait four months for
like you know the Atlantic or New Yorker
or someone to write like an amazing
piece on it is always more interesting
than following the day-to-day my
favorite uh Twitter feed autism Capital
who's been covering this whole story has
said that Michael Lewis the guy who
wrote The Big Short has been like
embedded with him for the past six
months writing a book and that he's
still involved and so I have a feeling
good it was meant to be like The Blind
Side it was meant to be this like you
know uh this like rag you know sort of
like
this was you know Wonder blind side
style story what's that you said it's
supposed to be like The Blind Side yeah
like a positive story right big short
was basically like here's you know this
thing that was you know destined to fail
I think he was following him not
thinking FTX is destined to fail but
thinking you know these are the
challengers you know and look at look at
the crazy craziness that's going on but
like not I don't think he was following
him and I don't think SBF let him in
because Michael Lewis was thinking it's
just a matter of time until this blows
up and this will be the big fraud in the
big Scandal like just like the big short
part two
um you know so so I think that that's
the interesting part it's like well
here's your here's your surprise twist
ending uh that you got here I will say
there's this one guy Jason Choi that
wrote a Twitter thread that is the best
Andrew if you want to read the
equivalent of the book or the the New
Yorker piece like I wouldn't wait for
them because a the New York Times put
out a piece on on SBF That was supposed
to be the um you know the sort of like
the recap and it was like incredibly
soft on him it was sort of just made him
out to seem like a good guy and um you
know oh some bad things have happened to
happen and this guy Jason Troy wrote out
this Twitter thread that's very clear
and it has all of the evidence in a
timeline that we know so far and it is
uh it's pretty compelling you should
check that one out have you guys pulled
it up have you guys ever come have you
guys ever had contact with someone who's
now famous fraud I've I've never I've
like never met someone who like was a
blatant liar uh about things that like
kind of became well known
I've told the story about the guy I
worked with the king of coal in
Indonesia who ended up in jail and
passed away in jail and but he wasn't a
fraud was he he was just a criminal I
mean he did better like he he like like
well no no no it's way different it's
like uh uh someone you know who's like
like what do you do for a living well I
rob people versus Like Bernie
Madoff who's like why I run a bank you
know people who still tend to lie
um and and you know so I think that yeah
this guy was bribing people but it
wasn't just let's say bribery you know
there was obviously gonna be other
things in an organization in an
organization like that where you're if
your primary agenda is to make as much
money as possible as quickly as possible
and you have great success doing it
um but you're not doing a ton of the
value creation yourself you know there's
there's often a um
you know both there's often both going
on and you know I I was able to
see a little bit of it what I what I saw
mostly was just the sort of like the the
fact that okay I guess that's the way
you do business in these countries you
kind of got to grease the the the guy in
the middle and that's how you get the
thing uh you know the sort of bribery
corruption is very common in India and
Indonesia in a bunch of different places
and so that part was known it was an
Open Secret
um but I'm you know it's not like if you
had if you'd ask me at that point in
time is there anything else going on I
wouldn't have been able to tell you
anything specific but I would have bet a
lot of money that there was something
else going on and it's part of the
reason why I wanted to leave eventually
so so I am most of the frauds that I've
met have always been small time so it'll
be like I meet someone and I ask around
about them and someone's like hey like
you know they've gone through the city
and got like ten thousand dollars from
all these investors and like defrauded
them but it's small time enough that
they get away with it um Charlie Munger
calls them the rats and The Granary you
can't really do anything about them
because they're too small they're always
going to be there and if you uh you know
you Hammer them once they're just gonna
come back in some other form
um I met a guy
um this is a bigger one so
um in in the Canadian stock market
there's tons of Fraud and there's very
little enforcement and
um often what you'll see is something
will get hot so like you know oh uh
vertical farming is hot so they'll find
some you know guy with like five
employees who has a vertical farming
business and some investment banker in
the public market will say hey let's
dress this up as the next great thing
and then what they do is they dump it to
retail investors so they go to Mom and
Pop and the investment banker calls them
and says hey I've got this amazing deal
we're going to IPO it it's going to pop
whatever and they hand the candy out and
often what ends up happening is you know
as the trend goes so you know as
marijuana stocks or fake meat or cubic
farming or whatever it is it pops and
then it drops and what happens is the
investment bankers often make a killing
because they get paid in warrants and
they get paid a percentage of the money
they raise so if they raise 100 million
dollars they might get paid five million
dollars plus warrants and if it pops
maybe those warrants end up being worth
10 million dollars and this is all legal
this is totally legal and so it's
basically legal stealing right so they
go out they raise all the money from a
bunch of you know grandmas and doctors
and normal people stock pops they sell
and then it goes to zero and all the
employees get laid off and the company
goes bankrupt or it's kind of a shell of
its former self
um and I met a guy
at a party
um you know last uh last summer and he
was bragging to me about this IPO that
he had done and how much money he made
and I started digging into it and it was
literally a the equivalent of taking a
corner store public this was like a two
location business and he dressed it up
to match a trend how much did they make
probably made I don't know I could
probably do the math but it's I would
argue probably five to five to twenty
million dollars doing this and you know
he's bragging about it and the stock is
down I think to like 10 cents or
something right it just it turned into
nothing and so it's crazy because it's
literally legal it's legal stealing
right like everything he did is
technically legal they do all the right
documents when they take it public they
disclose all the details they just write
it in the right way and it doesn't hurt
his reputation because he's behind the
scenes and like you know no one knows
and lots of people flip the stock too
right so many of his early investors
probably just sold when it peaked out to
oh you know what are called bag holders
in in the industry and then those people
lost all their money and so it's they
hurt let's say 10 000 people in a very
small way and so it's just not the sort
of thing that gets a lot of attention
from Regulators so I find that kind of
gross and crazy and there's a ton of
that up here in Canada so I uh tweeted
this out let's see when was this this
was basically last year February 2021
and I said esport Investments are a joke
there's so much dumb money in the space
look at this billion dollar publicly
traded company in Canada and Esports is
another one of those like kind of hot
industries that that you're talking
about and the ticker is eglx so I showed
this graph and I was basically like look
at this thing it's trading at 8.59
so I said um you know it's basically
it's a whole Co of random assets it's
got like a website for The Sims they own
a minority stake and the OverWatch team
of Vancouver
um it's not necessarily a bad company
but it's definitely not a billion dollar
company and so it's like here's some of
the things that they bought they bought
Luminosity the team uh the Esports team
they bought it for 1.5 million in cash 7
million in stock what's the company
called again I want to look it up I'll
tell you in a second because the the
prediction came true here's the spoiler
so uh eglx is the ticker so it was 8.59
when I wrote this it is now trading at
what
83.84 oh my gosh so yeah what's the
market cap so it's down 90 uh since I
wrote this thing uh 126 million how does
it even have 126 million it's not worth
100 spoiler it's gonna go down another
90 from here it's my guess uh not to
pick on these guys but just like there's
a lot of this happening I met uh other
people you know who are doing the same
thing and it seems to happen on these
small exchanges in Canada and stuff like
that
um so they bought Luminosity for a
million million and a half in cash seven
and a half million stock they bought
some agencies for 13 million in stats
cash some more stock and uh they started
trading on the TSX and then they were up
for 4X in a year and it's basically an
ad agency and then they own you know a
couple Niche websites
um and like you know if you add in all
of the things that they bought you know
they did 30 million in Revenue with 50
million expenses you know they lost 20
million dollars this year and they
called themselves a uh you know billion
dollar company and so you know like I
said people want to invest in a rocket
ship this is a sparkler they have 8
million of cash left in the bank it
looks like they're gonna need to raise
more money if they want to keep this
going and so uh you know I didn't even
remember that until you just said this
thing you said I was like I think I saw
some esport thing in Canada and
sure enough this was it
yeah there's endless numbers of these I
mean it happens in the states too you
guys saw Nikola where you know even the
name you're like okay Tesla Nikola Tesla
like you're just trying to grab onto
this trend and they you know basically
faked that they had this um uh what is
it I forget hydrogen powered
um electric semi truck and it turned out
they were just rolling it down the hill
and turning the camera so it looked like
it was driving on a flat surface
um complete fraud complete fraud like
commercial yes I'll link you guys to um
so there's this amazing guy named Nate
Anderson he has a short selling uh hedge
fund called Hindenburg research and he
writes these amazing research reports
where he takes down these companies and
it's just facts right it's like all he
does is just basic diligence and he'll
find like oh like it turns out Trevor
Milton the guy who is the CEO of Nicola
was accused of all these crimes and if
you just do basic research on this guy
AI obviously this guy is a fraud and
he'll write these amazing research
reports um here I'll send you guys one
no this guy his his stuff was good he's
he uh I mean he's a short seller so
obviously he's gonna be a hater but his
stuff is usually well researched and fun
to read
yeah I mean I think there's I there's
crappy short sellers who are gonna you
know make stuff up or you know hint at
stuff and then there's short sellers
that are basically journalists that just
share what's going on do you guys do you
guys remember bird Sean do you remember
bird in San Francisco scooter company
okay so scooter company that I don't
remember how much they raised but I
believe it was a 2.5 billion dollar
evaluation and I bet they've raised
north of four or five hundred yeah I
think I think they've raised over a
billion dollars let me see they've they
raised over a billion dollars yeah
they're they've raised more than it's
currently worth and I think it's
currently so listen to this listen to
this Google what it's worth right now
so they took it public at a three
billion dollar valuation I think it's
currently trading right now at 70
million dollars 70. okay they raised 883
million is that crazy this company is is
the market cap is 73 I think million
bucks
wait which company bird bird scooters do
you guys think they have to have at
least 70 million of scooters well and
how much secondary how much secondary
did the founders see which I I don't I
can't blame them to be honest I don't
blame them it was so hot but still but I
but I don't know how much he took but I
always like stick with like the best way
to figure out uh you know how wealthy
someone is is by looking at how
expensive their home is because it's
kind of hard to like get a fake mortgage
that way uh and Travis the guy who
founded it if you Google his name and
like house you'll see like you know uh
Tech entrepreneurs selling 10 million
dollar home in Santa Monica or Tech
entrepreneur buying 20 million dollar
home in Miami so he's he bought he's I
think he's bought two houses that are
worth tens of millions of dollars so
he's definitely they're selling I've got
a really quick thing if we have time
yeah
so
um do you guys remember I did this thing
called a non-binary term sheet a couple
years ago yeah
so you're you're on that non-binary
train before everyone else was dude
exactly exactly so so I've always found
I've always found Venture really tricky
right because someone will come to you
and they'll say
um you know I am going to revolutionize
XYZ industry and I'm going to create a
billion dollar business and I always say
okay well if you don't create the
billion dollar business then I lose all
my money right and to me that a it sucks
for the founder because if they
um you know get a bunch of money at a
valuation that's too high they can never
make their investors happy and it sucks
for the investor because it's binary
either they lose all their money or uh
or it goes and so when I was raising
money for supercast a couple years ago I
wanted to get what the market rate was
for valuation but I also wanted it to be
fair because for me I didn't want to
feel like if the business didn't
pan out I knew that if the business
didn't pan out to be a huge business it
could actually be a good smaller
business and so we raised it a 10
million dollar valuation which at the
time was kind of a good
um you know angel angel round valuation
but it was structured so that within two
years if the business doesn't do a
million dollars of Revenue that turns
into a five million valuation and so it
ended up we we did uh close to a million
dollars but we didn't hit it and so I
crammed myself down by 50 to make it
fair now I know a lot of Founders
wouldn't want to do this because why
would you do this
um you know other than to be a Boy Scout
and you know have a sense of fairness if
no one else is doing it and if VCS
expect this but I think it's a really
interesting structure and we've been
offering it to more and more Founders as
the environment changes where we say
look we'll invest but it has to be
structured so that if you don't deliver
on what you say you're gonna do we can
still get our money back what do you
guys think about that
I I don't love it for two reasons one is
what you just said which is like why
would a Founder do it uh like if I think
about it from the Founder's perspective
if I don't have to do that I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna do that right
like traditional Venture would just be a
better deal for me as a as a Founder in
that case
um and the other thing is I think it
creates weird incentives like
um I like the concept behind it like I
like the spirit of it but then I'm like
okay who's gonna set these benchmarks
and then what happens when the thousand
different things can happen in a
business and like you you said it
yourself like we got close but we didn't
get there and then there's like this
crazy urge to like do something to nudge
it over the top and now you're doing
something that may not be long term
um you know right for the business and
so you create some weird Dynamics I
wouldn't say it's worse Dynamics than it
currently exist
um it's just more like if I'm the
founder I would rather
um already and I also think I'd rather
take the Venture path where I'm getting
a higher valuation and selling less of
my business I would also say
there is a sort of like we're going for
it or we're not like you would if you're
running a pro like my eCommerce business
we run to maximize ebitda like yes we
want to grow it but it's like this thing
needs to make profits every year whereas
one of you did Venture things it was
like we don't think about that we think
about you know how are we going to grow
users let alone Revenue let forget about
profits altogether and so there is like
sort of like a there is a benefit in
knowing which path which blueprint of
business you're trying to build and then
being able to go all in on a strategy
that's aligned with that versus a
strategy where you're hedging but you're
like maybe we should yeah
sorry go ahead but Andrew the my whole
like I see all these I think there's
this like I've seen this like this thing
called the like hustle fun and all a few
other funds and they're like we're
trying to do things differently in my
opinion on that is why like the game
isn't broken the game works as it should
the the thing that's broken is people
who are joining and playing the game and
they maybe shouldn't be playing the game
but it works perfectly fine like we are
getting our desired example Sam of where
that's not true necessarily there are
certain businesses that are good
businesses but they're not good Venture
businesses
um and then they have they have a lack
of access to Capital so I forgot the
guy's name I feel bad now he's kind of
like it's kind of like an ndvc thing
they're doing they created Tyler is it
Tyler that what's it called the seal
agreement or this something like that
they have like some new type of dock
that's like the nine not non-binary term
but that's not but that's not VC right I
mean you would consider that's almost
like PE that's a different category yeah
but I guess what I'm saying is it's a
funding it's a funding option it's a
it's an alternative funding option for a
technology business right right that's
what I'm saying it's alternative to VC
what I'm saying is Venture Capital as we
know it I think it works perfectly fine
like it's the the way it's supposed to
work is uh some get it uh most don't the
and the some that do get it most fail
and very few become huge life-changing
things and don't but don't you think
like okay so Sean let's say that you got
really bullish about your e-commerce
concept and you'd raise 10 million
dollars like let's say like in the age
of Casper when e-commerce is super hot
and d2c is crazy and the valuations are
high and you go out and you raise 10
million dollars and now you're stuck
where you're going you know what I
really want is to Pivot this into a
lifestyle business because that's what's
logical for what you want and imagine if
there's a structure where you didn't
have to feel like a piece of
because you can never get your investors
money back right and what I've seen is
the incentive creates this situation
where the founder is sitting on a
business that could make them happy and
give them a great lifestyle but they
have a gun to their head and so they
continue down the Venture path even when
it's actually futile and won't work and
they drive the business into the ground
so it's worse for the employees it's
worse for the founders it's worse for
the investors as well because the
investors just go to zero instead of at
least making a reasonable return so and
it is kind of like private Equity but
you gotta remember private Equity
doesn't take risk on what could be right
private equity invests in what is they
will say your business does 10 million
dollars ebitda I'm going to assume it's
going to be 11 12 13 14 not Venture
which is your business does 200k revenue
you're assuming you're going to get to 2
and then 20 over the next three years
right right so it's a different form of
capital in my opinion but isn't the
problem like let's say I take that 10
million and I take it where I sell let's
just say 10 of the company in that round
and what you're saying is that in the
event that things don't grow as fast two
years now from now
um that 10 becomes thirty percent for
the same 10 million dollars it becomes
whatever it just yeah numbers like that
totally so um but isn't the problem that
they probably have burned the 10 million
along the way trying to get the thing to
grow hiring people marketing whatever
else they're going to do and now they
still need money now they have all these
people so you're gonna have basically
like a combination of things it's like
we're gonna have to lay off a bunch of
people probably as we shift strategies
to more of the lifestyle type of
business to be more profitable we're
gonna ratchet up those investors who go
from 10 to 30 percent the 10 million is
gone so I still need money to run the
thing most likely I need to maybe raise
additional Capital so I'm going to raise
more money but on those lower terms
dilute everybody it just becomes kind of
like I have this like it's a sad rainy
day now or am I thinking about it I
think I just fundamentally have a
problem with Founders who raise money at
a very very high valuation with the
knowledge especially from people who are
not VCS right so you know you've seen a
lot of this
um there's lots of people in our world
who have raised very like on businesses
that you know we've looked at and would
value it like maybe five or ten million
dollars and they've gone on crowdfunding
platforms or something can you give an
example tons of money
no but there's lots of people and
there's I'm not singling anyone out
literally there's like 10 or 20 examples
I can think of and frankly it's like
it's opportunistic I get it you know you
want to raise on great terms but I have
a fundamental problem with taking money
from someone when I know I can't give
them a return or there's like a five
percent chance and positioning it as you
know you're investing in this super
solid awesome thing that's going to be
huge or as cash flowing or whatever and
you're basically just taking someone
from it's like going to someone in real
estate and selling them on your Tech
startup that we would all know as a bag
of garbage but because they're in real
estate they go oh this looks great yeah
I actually I I agree with you 100 and I
I really really dislike that I tweeted
something out that I want to get you
guys this is a reaction to so I tweeted
something that kind of uh I don't know
Ruffles some feathers I guess so I go
like a one lesson uh let me pull it up
exactly yeah I like this one I don't say
it wrong but um I don't understand how
this ruffled feathers but go ahead I go
this year I learned there is no quote
smart money Andreessen Sequoia tiger
tribe kotu SoftBank Paradigm Alameda FTX
they all made terrible financial
decisions at huge size and yet most will
get richer
they play a rigged game uh chamoth made
money off of a bunch of his shitty
spacks because he's the promoter and
these funds manage billions of dollars
and they'll make hundreds of millions in
fees along the way as a reward even if
they lose their investors money
um they don't invest they didn't these
aren't just companies that they invest
in that start to underperform these are
huge bets on fundamentally flawed assets
it's crazy but the lesson for me
remember to think for myself don't use
the justification that the big name is
investing as any sort of signal and
remember that the smart money is just as
dumb as me so I tweeted this out I did
it really fast I probably should have
worded it differently but a bunch of
people from these firms didn't really
like what I was saying I think do they
DM you or comment DM uh come on the
courage to comment and get into a tiff
about this no way there's no way they're
gonna they're gonna take that chance
um you know what and I think the the I
think part of it is I worded it poorly I
think they thought I was saying
these people who are supposed to be
smart are dumb and evil and I think it's
because I said like you know they play a
rigged game I stole that from christaka
who was a VC he goes venture capital is
a rig game you make money on the fees
regardless of whether you get returns or
not and then you get their carry on the
returns to uh down the road seven to ten
years later before you know before
anyone figures out if you're any good at
this or not
um but you know I think they people
thought I was calling them dumb and evil
and actually no I think they're very
smart my point was actually that even
the very smart people are doing some
really dumb things because it's a really
hard game and
um
and I gotta remember to like you know
not use their conviction in something to
override my own
either cluelessness or lack of
conviction in something and be like yeah
this is a good this is I guess it's a
good idea these guys are doing it I
guess I should put money in these guys
are doing like the fomo investing uh
style you know I got burned on it
I think this is one of the dirtiest
things in our industry so
um you know if you're in private Equity
or you run a hedge fund you know if
you're an idiot or a genius in months or
years right when you're playing Venture
you can take 10 to 15 years to see what
a fund really does and yeah there's
markups and all this other stuff but at
the end of the day to see realized gains
takes a very very long time and so what
you'll see is you know someone raises
100 million and then 500 million and
then a billion and on a billion they're
getting a two percent management fee so
they're getting 20 million dollars a
year and let's think about what are the
costs to run a venture capital firm
you've got someone as a custodian
managing your fund you could if you
wanted probably have three or four
employees I know benchmark manages three
billion plus with like 12 or 15 people
so these are not expensive businesses to
operate and I think that
um they make money guaranteed every year
and by the time that investors realize
that over a 10 in your period they've
underperformed they've already made
hundreds of millions of dollars it's
just absurd for taking very limited risk
themselves and they win no matter what
and so I think this is something that
will go away in the long term and I'm
frankly shocked that when you raise a
venture fund you don't have to say this
is my budget I'm going to hire three
Associates and my salary is this that's
all I'm charging you in fees instead
they get this thing where it's like you
get 20 million dollars of fees and if
you spend two million dollars a year on
the office you make 18 million dollars a
year it's total hustle
um and this is why like our ruling fund
and our private fund we don't cover we
don't do any management fees whatsoever
because I'm allergic to this I find it
really gross yeah that is crazy two
years of my fund I took zero management
fees and then as I hired people then I
added the fund but also my font is so
small that two percent management fee of
my fund is 200 000 a year it's less than
what I'm paying people to doing it I am
I am taking a loss on my on the salaries
uh you know with that manager fee but
two percent of a billion dollars every
single year is 200 million dollars over
the life of that fund that you got as
risk-free reward which is insane and so
and then you know the other point I was
trying to make was that like
there are times when you bet on
something that's a business that's doing
really well a really healthy business
that hey you know it didn't achieve the
maybe it didn't get as far as we thought
it would so it was a 2X instead of a 20x
or the something in the market dynamics
changed a competitor or regulation or
the economy slow down and then they slow
down and they they didn't end up you
know achieving the dream that they had
versus like the investors invest in FTX
if you're putting like like Paradigm
Paradigm is the number one like you know
crypto VC crypto focused VC and they put
290 million dollars into FTX right 300
million dollar bet
um and they came out the other day they
go we are writing our investment down to
zero um we want to assure you that this
was a small portion of our overall funds
and we had no idea what was going on uh
like we didn't know about this and you
you think about it you're like first of
all the fact that a 300 million dollar
bet is a small portion of your overall
thing like that's true I'm not saying
that that's not true because you have a
three billion or whatever fund
but man when people when when an
outsider reads that ft uh that Paradigm
puts 300 million to FDX they assume a
couple things FTX is probably a good
business and that Paradigm the smartest
guys in the room are probably doing
diligence to say hey is this guy
literally funneling customer money into
his like his own trade hedge fund and
like going and gambling with that money
or not right like you would hope that
somebody's doing the diligence and so um
you know I think that that's that's the
case not to pick on Paradigm I still
think these guys are really smart
um it just sort of shows in general that
the amount of diligence you would assume
happens on large bet sizes like that is
actually uh you know nowhere near what
it what it could or probably should be
and secondly like you have people like
um like chamoth when he was doing his
back for Metro Mile right like you know
we've named basically a couple
businesses that all in pod I think these
guys are super awesome I love the
podcast uh they're super smart and
successful that's there's no no doubt
about that but you talked about bird you
know David Sachs was the lead investor I
think it bird for like multiple rounds
uh if I'm not mistaken and um you know
bird now is a 70 million dollar company
but you know these guys cashed out at
the IPO probably you know over a billion
dollars and you know
you know there you go you're done uh
these guys were months ago laughing
about Solana and how they you know just
received all the Solana at the super low
price they can't wait to dump it and um
and you know now they're you know finger
pointing at other people in crypto for
doing the same that for doing the same
thing but not acknowledging it or you
know chamat took uh friedberg's company
Metro mile public through Speck and said
Buffett had Geico I have Metro mile A
Better Business in all these ways and
like I don't know less than a year later
Metro mile sells for a third of what it
went public for
um you know it's a lemonade and so you
you know you see the stuff you think are
these people lying though I don't think
that they're lying it's just that
investing in business is a really really
hard game and even the smartest people
in the room are making really dumb
things really making really dumb
decisions or dumb bets
um and in some cases they have unfair
advantages that you don't have so it was
a reminder to myself and to many other
people out there who don't have those
unfair advantages that
um you cannot take their backing or
their involvement in a project as a
signal that this is a winner or a good
thing that's my rant when you just think
about how much more powerful it would be
if chimath like I would have a lot of
respect if he had said look you know we
took Metro mile public I thought it was
my Geico I put 200 million dollars 20 of
my net worth into this business and I
lost it alongside of you
um or I invested my warrants into equity
and I I locked it up and I held it for
three years or something like that but
no there's nothing like that there's no
alignment and I think so often this
comes down to alignment of incentives
um you know they're they're incentivized
to do the bad thing what was the General
sentiment of the DM Sean
like semantics will stuff first like we
wait we weren't an FTX it's like dude
I'm not talking about FTX I'm talking
about these other three shitty bets if
you need me to name the names I'll I'll
do it that you know this thing you
invested that made zero sense you know
blah blah so it's like some was we
didn't make this mistake and then the
other one is look this is just the
nature of the game it's Venture you
should know this but you have a venture
fund like you know you're gonna have a
bunch of zeros and I said I totally
agree you know I invest in seed you know
startup ideas that are you know summer
routine a pitch deck a prototype or you
know early stage product I know a lot of
these aren't going to work out it's very
different than I put 50 or 100 or 300
million dollars into a business that was
fundamentally like you know fraudulent
or was like doing something that was uh
um you know sort of self-dealing that's
that's very very different than um you
know we bet on this technology and it
turned out the costs weren't and it cost
didn't work out or that traction wasn't
it didn't grow as fast as we had hoped
or whatever there's different way ways
to lose in the same way I always say in
our business like there's errors of
action and errors of inaction if you're
trying really hard and you make mistakes
totally acceptable if your error is that
you didn't think about it or you didn't
do anything you forgot you just dropped
the ball on it that's where I have
trouble and the same thing in investing
well in here you can you can misjudge a
business and think it was going to grow
faster or you know it got sideswiped by
something else versus
um
if you put something into you put money
into something that you should have
diligence and you did
to me this is like yeah if a16z on
average delivers value right so as a
portfolio they've created all this
Innovation they've invested all these
great companies and yes there's going to
be some colossal mess-ups where they're
going to lose a ton of money I think
that's great what makes me sad is when
you take the holistic result of an
entire firm and you go wow over a
10-year period they made tons of money
and all their investors lost a bunch of
money or all these businesses were zeros
that I think is the hard part and again
this is a decades game right chamoth we
won't know if chamath has actually built
value for another 10 or 20 years and
frankly like his it's all very like
secret because I think a lot of this
stuff is private so we really have no
clue how much money he has how much
money he made what's been successful
what hasn't there's a bit of a smoke
screen there
um and I you know I've talked to chamoth
before I think he's like a super nice
Charming smart guy and I like you I
listen all in and I I like those guys
and at the same time I go you know wow
there's some there's some games yeah and
again I'm not saying that they do a bad
job or that they did anything bad I'm
just saying the reminder to myself was
just because this really smart person
who you respect and is generally
successful and has made money and
probably will continue to make money is
in something
like you can't Outsource your conviction
like you can Outsource a lot of you
can't Outsource your conviction so that
was really what I was trying to say I
think I got a little too heated up and
made it sound like they were dumb or
evil but that really wasn't what I was
trying to say it was actually they are
smart but even even though they're smart
they're gonna make some colossal
mistakes along the way they will
probably end up fine but you got to make
sure that you know that you go in Eyes
Wide Open that smart person can do dumb
things and it sounds so simple but it's
like a reality is we all do this we all
take mental shortcuts oh if these guys
are in we're in if this if they say it's
good it probably is good right and you
have to do that to some extent or you
can't function I can't sit here in
diligence every business on Earth but uh
you know you have to be you have to at
the end of the day you have to the
reminder was to myself make sure if I
bet on anything and I wasn't an investor
in FTX for example but like let's say I
let's say I was or an investor in crypto
or you know promoted Sam as a smart guy
like
you have to try to
um
try to not lean on other big names as
your source of conviction
totally I I remember I read um Howard
Mark's book so he's like a famous
billionaire uh investor value investor
and specializes in distressed debt and I
read his book and I went wow this guy's
amazing what a great investor and I
realize there's ways to see what they
were buying so you can find out what all
your favorite investors Buy in the stock
market and so I went well I totally
trust this guy I read his book it's
incredible
um I'm gonna buy into this weird Greek
shipping company that he just bought you
know 50 million dollars of equity in and
so I put like 100 Grand into it and it
goes out of business and what I didn't
understand was two things one he has
thousands of positions right or hundreds
at least and for him it's just a tiny
little roulette chip that he's put down
and two he's a distressed debt investor
so he might buy the equity but he's
buying all mostly focused on the debt
and expecting it to go out of business
so I actually screwed myself by not
understanding and just blindly going
along with it and I've made that same
mistake you know hundreds of times
[Music]